andrea o'bailey out there they're going
to let him take that shot and try to
protect inside out
a little step back from the ant-man
[Music]
total package cross it over
against banks with a step high kiss goes
and the foul
over arguably the nation's best shot
blocker
anthony edwards and his crowd his home
crowd
love it that pass is nearly a
possibility
edwards ahead of the pack rising fire he
got it
anthony edwards rises up and you can
tell he
he likes shooting at pull up three it
doesn't matter how deep
batiste with six assists fitzgibbons has
it stripped away
edwards with plenty of time what a
crossover
in the right-handed finish because the
citadel had it
down six oh my goodness what a move
stolen away edwards and showtime
whoa
[Applause]
they put a little exclamation point with
the high flying tomahawk right there
wow sec freshman of the week highlighted
him in the open had 20 the other night
he can really score
this hasn't gotten comfortable yet oh
there's edwards
[Applause]
wow look at that fish oh man
it doesn't look like he's trying that
hard to get out ahead but
he's out ahead they've been very active
on the defensive end
there it is again edwards he has a
chance here in the open floor
first half of basketball but they
certainly have enjoyed their second half
watch out i think the whole band on that
one
andrea bailey out there they're gonna
let him take that shot and try to
protect inside out
a little step back from the ant-man
watch this
create a little separation terrific
skill to get into the rhythm of his jump
shot
they extended the coach's box up the
sideline made it a whole lot easier
for coaches
edward all the way to the rim oh
my goodness the ant-man watch this
and then by the way after not calling it
a foul went to the monitor to see
if it was going to be a flavored one
what up it's your boy adam lefkow did
you like that content i know you like
that content hit subscribe
for more of it from bleacher report